good morning Hank it's Tuesday Oh it's
some kind of reunion video hi okay hey
this is a very special edition of
question Tuesday in which I ask you
questions that contained the word first
just like it's like first comment does
that's actually my first question how do
you feel about people writing first in
the comments of YouTube videos he used
to bother me John it doesn't bother me
like every time I am first oh yeah right
I can't stop myself right I used to
bother me until I was like until I was
first on a video and I was like I have
to I want to do this Hank you remember
the first movie that made you cry
americantale I think it was americantale
Hank what are your best first-aid tips
all the doctor no no apply pressure to
the wound
what if there's no wound just apply
pressure pressure pressure that's that I
can confirm that Sun Pleasant do not
touch the couch under any circumstances
this is an incredibly delicate setup we
got is not particularly strict I think
what was the first book you fell in love
with Jurassic Park really yeah move
possibly like the sequel The Lost world
yeah Wow really no for me it was Gus is
a bug what was your first broken bone I
think one of these incorrect oh you
remember I do what was it you fell out
of a tree house and you broke your arm
no I did not you did it did not you
definitely did call mom okay did I ever
fall out of a tree mom do you ever
remember me break my bones falling on
the tree house a tree house who did oh
you you fell out of a tree house as a
memory of myself
let me how brains work I think what was
your first concert I think it was
probably there might be John I think it
was they might be joints I remember it
you were young you were 11 okay were you
you were there yeah my first concert may
have been the b-52s now that I'm
thinking about it I think the b-52s
opened for the violin the violin bends
open for the b-52s Hank do you remember
the first time you saw a snowfall I
remember the first time I saw snow on
the ground Alabama and I was like
it's a thing the first time I saw
snowfall I was fully like 9 or 10 years
old yeah and I was astonished because I
thought snowflakes were like the ones
that you make an element out of school
yeah I thought they were about that big
I thought they were made up I'm a dumb
idea and then I saw a snowflake and I
was like it's the shape yeah I thought
that about moonlight I thought that I
also thought that about this is weird
because we lived in like street lights
central yeah like the first time you
like have a shadow cast by the moon
you're like what what's casting that
shadow oh it's like does this mean I'm a
werewolf
I thought moonlight was like I don't
know like passenger pigeons like
something that had a time that had
passed just over somehow yeah I think do
you remember your first tweet don't
worry I already wrote it down in case
you don't remember it was probably like
I'm starting up Twitter now let's see
how that knows no that was my first
tweet your first tweet was in June of
2007 back on your eco geek handle and I
was writing up some stories for eco geek
wondering when Google will buy Twitter
oh if only they had yeah I mean it still
kind of makes sense but Google has such
a successful existing social network in
Google+ egg when was the last time you
did something for the first time so the
first time I've had all of these cells
it's the first time that I've probably
ever worn this outfit do you know the
last time you leave something for the
first time oh yeah yeah okay dftba I
will see you right now don't continue to
see you yeah